تم العد في وقت مبكر من الحرب ولكن لا
تزال قوية رغم
كل الصعاب التي لم تنجح روسيا
في إيقاف القوات الجوية الأوكرانية ،
تحدثنا إلى الطيار المقاتل أندريه الذي كان
في مكان غير معلوم وكان يخفي
هويته لأسباب تتعلق بالسلامة
في البداية ، حيث سيطر الطيارون الروس على
عدد من  المقاتلون والمعدات الأحدث
الآن بدأوا يرفضون الطيران
لأننا أطلقنا النار عليهم
نحاول العمل مع التكتيكات ويقول أندري إنه يقود
مقاتلة التفوق الجوي من طراز Su-27 ،
هذا فيديو قدمه الجيش الأوكراني
من نفس الطراز
طائرة قديمة ولكنها لا تزال فعالة ، لقد
أسقطت الطائرات الروسية للأسف
لا أستطيع تحديد أي منها وكم وكيف
أغلقتها بالضبط
صواريخ جو -
جو أطلقت صواريخ أرض - جو مرارًا وتكرارًا
كانت هناك رحلة عندما كنا  طار ثلاثة
ضد 24. هذا يعني أن مقاتلينا الثلاثة
صدوا هجوم 24 طائرتهم
من المستحيل بالنسبة لنا التحقق من هذه
الادعاءات ولكن خلال مقابلتنا سمعنا
ما بدا  إقلاع طائرة كرينية
[موسيقى]
يقول أندريه إن الولايات المتحدة ساعدته في
تعليمه ورفاقه من الطيارين كيفية التغلب على
الروس ،
فلدينا تكتيكاتنا التي أجريناها
مع أصدقائنا الأمريكيين ،
ونحن الآن نستخدم بعض
التكتيكات التي تعلمناها من الأمريكيين
اعتقدت الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤها في البداية
أن روسيا ستمتلك الأجواء فوق
أوكرانيا بعد أيام قليلة من غزوها ،
لكن المتحدث باسم القوات الجوية الأوكرانية
يقول إنهم
مستعدون لهذا السيناريو
لمدة ثماني سنوات ، ولا يمكن القول إن
جيشنا لم يفعل ذلك.  أعتقد أن هذا
لن يحدث ،
لقد دمرنا مائة طائرة و
123 طائرة هليكوبتر
بالفعل تم إسقاط الكثير من الطائرات الروسية
بواسطة صواريخ تطلق من الكتف
قدمها الحلفاء الغربيون ، لكن
الأوكرانيين ما زالوا يشغلون
أنظمة أطول مدى مثل إس
-300 جو.  المتحدث باسم القوة يقول إن أوكرانيا
تريد صواريخ غربية وطائرات أمريكية
أتحدث عن أنظمة الدفاع الجوي المتكاملة لحلف شمال الأطلسي
وهي f-15 eagle أو f-16
fight fal  لكونهم قد يكونون غير مستخدمين أو تم
إيقاف تشغيلهم ، لكنهم يمكن أن يخدموا
الجيش الأوكراني
لأندريه ، فإن المعركة من أجل سماء
أوكرانيا هي معركة شخصية تساعد كل من
والدته وزوجته في الجهود المبذولة
لصد الروس كما يقول
وهو أيضًا على استعداد  للتضحية
بالجميع خائفين من القتل ،
فإن الموت بشرف شيء آخر
هو الموت بدون
شرف ، وقد قالت الولايات المتحدة إن القوات الجوية الأوكرانية
لا تزال سليمة إلى حد كبير وأن القتال
جاهز للمعركة من أجل السماء منطقة أخرى
حيث هذه الأمة المتفوقة عليها
المثابرة رغم كل الصعاب